so you're saying the universe created a
sitcom starring two avengers
it's a working theory what's up
everybody carlos here if there's one
thing that's true about mcu fans it's
that we are incredibly invested i mean
the last few weeks of juan division
chatter
is proof of all that well of course
marvel knows this
and in episode 4 of their disney plus
series
they're totally trolling us major
spoilers at the head
this is e.t candidates
the big reveal this week revolves around
the mysterious agencies set up around
west view
that's been keeping an eye on wanda and
vision in their sitcom life
and like we suspected it is in fact the
sentient weapon observation response
division
or sword for short so that little red
helicopter
a sword drone the beekeeper a sword
agent
and geraldine well she's finally
revealed as monica rambo
sword in fact monica is introduced to us
in the beginning
of the episode in a way that's very
significant to mcu fans
by re-materializing as part of the blip
the event that saw half the world's
population disappear due to thanos snap
and then reappear when the infinity
stones were returned after his defeat
monica returns the sword the house her
mother built nice little
photon easter egg in there and her first
assignment back
sets everything into motion captain
rambo
captain rambo a couple of familiar faces
also make their anticipated returns in
this episode
randall park as fbi agent jimmy wu and
kat dennings as astrophysicist darcy
lewis
who we haven't seen since thor the dark
world darcy and jimmy are essentially
all of us from the past few weeks
watching superheroes star and sitcoms
and trying to figure out what the heck
we're all seeing brass tacks dr lewis
what are we looking at here is it an
alternate reality
time travel some cockamamie social
experiment it's a sitcom
a 1950 sitcom but why hey man we're
working with the same scarcity of intel
darcy says she found radiation called
cmbr which they say is radiation dating
back to the big bang
now this isn't just exposition the
infinity stones were created during the
big bang and as we know
the mind stone can control the minds of
others and it's the stone that gives
vision life
remember this detail it'll be on the
quiz later are you
wanda i'm just your neighbor and how did
you know about ultron
you're not my neighbor meanwhile one of
the biggest scenes in the series so far
gets a new point of view in this episode
as geraldine monica brings up pietro and
ultron to wanda we know this
now here you finally see how that
confrontation actually played out
with wanda seemingly fully aware of what
she's doing
and i want you
that intriguing reveal is followed up by
easily this episode's most
shocking moment
[Music]
what what is it what's wrong
[Music]
was that vision just a vision or is that
his true face
something we only see when wanda's spell
is broken for a moment
either way it freaked me out and i hope
it freaked you out too
fyi vision's supposed to be dead just in
case you didn't know and don't show the
clip again
we've all seen the clip too many times
though episode 4 has pulled back the
curtain on a few things that leaves us
once again with so many questions why
are these specific people
cast members in wanda sitcom what's up
with harold being
sit on it has wanda been in full control
this whole time
oh don't worry darling i have everything
under control
[Music]
and maybe most importantly who is
currently in control of the mind stone
which could very well be powering all of
this for all we know
it's actually jimmy i mean the dude
likes magic
james e woo fbi y'all know i'm joking
right
it's probably agnes there are a ton of
little easter eggs and weird moments in
this episode so if you see anything
significant
sound off in the comments below now if
you need to catch up on more super nerdy
news
click here or somewhere here i don't
know
and subscribe to get more of et canada's
nerd alert we do this
every week see you next time